people here say it feels like a
different place compared to the early
days of lockdown before Boris Johnson
got ill in this part of Birmingham there
are now more cars and more people on the
streets
according to window cleaner Allen
woulding who says the Prime Minister
should send a clear message he's back by
strengthening the lockdown not easing it
busier than what it is Boris Johnson
said crackdown you know when no the
police have got enough to do maybe ring
the army and to patrol certain areas
that's really right with people walking
around them Bryn's lockdown has never
been as strict as it was in other
European countries such as Italy and
that means the rewards in terms of Boris
Johnson's promised to send coronavirus
packing aren't being reached as quickly
we are sadly not seeing quite as a rapid
decline in the the UK as many of our
European neighbors have seen in their
countries and and I think we don't
really yet understand fully why why that
is and that needs to be something that
we addressed barely seen
no wonder the Prime Minister's standing
is refusing to raise hopes by discussing
an endgame for lockdown what we've said
very clearly is we've set out the five
tests for what the next transitional
phase would look like won't be just
going back it will be a new normal if
you like with social distancing measures
adapted to areas which are currently
closed off if you go too early with your
measures and I think there'll be
international experience when we're done
with this crisis it will bear this out
if you go too early you end up trying to
come out of it too early and that risks
the second spike but in a letter to the
Prime Minister the Labour leader Kirsten
has said the British public have made
great sacrifices to make the lockdown
work they deserve to be part of an adult
conversation about what comes next post
Boris Johnson has been away from his
desk a lot has changed many people are
still resolutely behind the lockdown
terrified by the continuing spread of
coronavirus others are fed up businesses
are questioning how long they can
survive
for amongst the voices trying to
influence the prime minister are people
like phones4u co-founder and Tory donor
John chord well I hate to be a doom
manga but the reality is that we are in
for a very very tough time post Corona
and the longer it goes in the top of
that times going to be but a key
government adviser says reopening the
country whilst shielding the elderly
would send the death rate shooting up if
you just achieve for instance 80 percent
shielding eighty percent reduction in
infection risk in those groups we'd
still project you get you know well over
a hundred thousand deaths later this
year that's what a strategy it's been
over three weeks since Boris Johnson was
last seen on the steps of Downing Street
in his absence Britain has gone past the
coronavirus peak but the crisis is far
from over
we saw Holland Sky News